entre sorprendida e indignada así es
cómo ha reaccionado turquía después de
que el presidente de los eeuu joe biden
de clara se reconociese este sábado por
la tarde el genocidio armenio ocurrido
en 1915 no sólo han sido miembros del
gobierno que han declarado esta decisión
de joe biden como un acto populista y
que han rechazado absolutamente sino que
también han sido miembros de la
oposición de los mayores partidos del
país exceptuando uno todos los demás
critican a las palabras de joe biden que
catalogan de políticamente a encaradas
en un momento de tensión enorme entre
turquía y los eeuu sólo un partido
estaba a favor del reconocimiento de
este genocidio contra la población
armenia en el imperio otomano es el
partido por kurdos del pp este partido
es muy criticado en turquía por el
nacionalismo turco recordemos que tanto
oposición como presidente recep tayip
erdogán son partidos muy nacionalistas y
precisamente este partido prokurdo está
siendo juzgado para ser cerrado uno de
los motivos es su apoyo a la lucha ya
los derechos de la población kurda del
país
y ahora mismo en turquía desde hace
decenas de años no se acepta que ocurrió
tal genocidio armenio al final del
imperio otomano y durante la primera
guerra mundial turquía asegura que esas
matanzas que ocurrieron de armenios
cerca de un millón de armenios
parecieron por ese genocidio declarado
por joe biden murieron como también
murieron turcos eso es lo que declara
turquía que ocurrió esa época sin
embargo el consenso internacional de los
expertos historiadores que sí que
ocurrió una campaña sistemática para
eliminar a los ciudadanos armenios
dentro del imperio otomano